what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I cover this week's
treachery debauchery and craziness
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way and also guys we
just dropped merch so I just made women
shouldn't vote t-shirts I I tweeted this
t-shirt it got 15 million views on
Twitter and a lot of really mad liberals
so if you want to go around town and
have women you know guys always talk
about picking up women right I'm helping
you guys out women will come up to you
all the time in the shirt
um so the link to that is in the
description it's at the audacity Network
dot store that's the audacity Network
dot store Okay so
today's topic so as you guys know I'm
always tweeting I'm like I'm like the
queen of Twitter I just tweet tweet
tweet tweet tweet tweet so yesterday I
was thinking
and I was thinking about how in society
how we can gather information from
listening to stories and hearing
patterns and so I was really curious
from the men what was the worst cheating
story that you've heard of so I had two
tweets I tweeted what is the worst
cheating story you heard of and what was
the red pill moment where you realized
women aren't as innocent as they seem
and I told my producers to pick out the
best of these stories all right so we
got Stephen Paul
I was with my wife and girlfriend for 20
years from 1980 married for 14. three
sons at the time we split were 10 8 and
3 years old a small two-bedroom home in
a nice neighborhood but was able to
expand to a nice five bedroom two-story
3 400 square foot home the problem was
the contractor my wife and I hired is
that they started dating while the house
was being built while I was at work
all the clues were there but I did not
see them until years later
hilarious Clues really I was not smart
enough to see them at the time it cost
me over 3 million in alimony and child
support and more in the corrupt family
court system
I'll never get married again
it's interesting because a lot of people
will demonize the men that walk away
from Marriage as just being guys that
can't get laid that women don't like
this man lost 3 million in the family
court system just imagine how much time
it took this guy to get that 3 million
and now he's losing it in the family
court system and guys for this to not be
a pattern is a little bit silly because
we have the old Trope of the pool boy
right and there's you know and there's a
reason in history
um they used to they used to castrate
slaves that worked for the guys because
they didn't want them screwing the wife
women have always been monkey branchers
we even just saw this with Tom Brady and
Gisele where right after the divorce
Giselle was seen with um their kids
karate instructor you know this is
definitely a pattern and a reason why uh
men you know quote unquote controlling
men keep their women away from certain
types of guys is because women have a
tendency to Monkey Branch AA USA 8 says
while at Sea during the Iranian hostage
crisis we had a large bulletin board
filled and overlapped by letter Sailors
had gotten from wives doing a divorce on
them mine came in a Christmas card
saying I want a divorce the bulletin
board was overfilled halfway through
deployment and the crew size was only
550. my card was added to the rest
coming home a large box was in front of
the kitchen sink overflowing with empty
bottles and beer canned cans that she
could not get rid of when I lifted it a
pair of her soiled panties were
underneath I thank the Sailor whoever he
was who left it there as a silent
confirming message
wow
this was during the Iranian hostage
crisis
these women are just divorcing their men
all right Mark Essence says GI Jane and
Will Smith is pretty cold interviewing
the guy so how did meet cuckolding you
make you feel and then her telling him
to slap Chris Rock publicly to protect
her honor and virtue that's
Shakespearean yeah guys this is what
happens when men are led by women women
just sort of lead to destruction I don't
know what it is about us I don't know
why we do this
but I I just don't see many
relationships that are female-led that
really lead to good things and you see
that with Will Smith and Jada you see
how the kids turned out when things are
out of order and they disrespect the
husband the men in the family grew up
being led by their emotions and the
women in the family grow up
disrespecting men it's a very common
Trope Felipe Pierre probably mine I've
been with her for four years and when we
started dating her son had just been
born I raised him as my own child she
asked her dentist out she came out with
him on a Thursday night and guess who
she used to take care of her child on
that day me
the audacity this is so crazy guys and
this is the thing this is modern
marriage
and you know I think you get a little
bit more honest responses on Reddit and
on Twitter and I know some stories
obviously are going to be made up but I
think the point is
this idea that marriage is just this
innocent thing where you can just find a
good woman and trust her
um is a little bit silly with the laws
being the way they are the media
pandering to us and other men lying to
us
um and this is the problem with
promiscuity
you know they say can you wife a hoe a
lot of hoes get married but the truth of
the matter is after about five partners
um and even at like three Partners
women's ability to stay happy married is
very low and they're going to be
consequences for men marrying hoes
all right
Godless heathrin says
why is that your username you guys have
the all right
just today I learned that a boss at my
job got caught cheating on camera
messing around with a female supervisor
while at work both were fired she was
pregnant at the time and had five other
kids and her husband worked there too
and everyone knows can you imagine that
guys imagine not only did you get
cheated on not only did people find out
you got cheated on
everyone you have to go to work
I would quit I would quit would you quit
King if that happened to you I would
quit
I would find a new job
and now I gotta work with the guy guy my
guy my wife cheated on
and my wife oh no I would quit I would
find a new job oh no couldn't be me if I
was a guy anyways
Elliot says when I was 13 years old my
brother was dating a girl who was about
24 years old she got me to go into her
room thinking she had to grab something
before we picked up my brother from work
and she seduced me into having sex with
her and my brother never forgave me for
it
oh that's so sad he's only 13.
and you know what's crazy I've heard
this story from so many guys either on
the show or just like guys that I know
where they lost their virginity from
like a babysitter it's really like
predatory women are absolutely real and
you see it all the time with like I
remember we had a teacher in high school
oh my gosh this woman would totally
flirt with all the guys it was so crazy
they would dress up like provocatively
at school and she was just like a ball
buster chick all right we have another
story I know a girl during uni who is
cheating on her boyfriend she would lie
to her boyfriend and tell him she was
going to study sometimes he would pick
her up and drop her off to study this is
five years ago they have four kids now
and the guy still has no idea
you know this reminds me I'll tell you
guys a cheating story I I've told the
story on the show so many times but you
know maybe you're new here when I was um
when I was at University or I'm at
College
um there was a girl on my team that was
with um
she was literally with
and I didn't know her super well but I
definitely saw her go into the bathroom
with like an ex-boyfriend of hers and
then her new boyfriend like showed up to
this place yeah and she ended up like I
think they're still together to this day
those were responses to my first tweet
my second tweet man what was your red
pill moment where you realized women
aren't as innocent as they seem Neely
when I found out my loving girlfriend
who called me at work every day at 6am I
worked overnight so she could go to
school to tell me how much she loved me
and appreciated me she was calling me
from the bedroom of the guy she was
cheating with I learned about it when he
sent her a letter to tell her off
because he found out she was sleeping
with someone else other than me and felt
cheated on that was the day I learned
there's no such thing as proof of love
and this is another thing that a lot of
women don't realize a lot of a lot of
players are made
they're not born that way I think guys
have a more idealistic sense of love
than women and I think of this because I
think of back to college in high school
when women had more of the leverage in
relationships and I didn't see women
behaving well with that leverage and I
think a lot of women string men on for
for years that they don't want to marry
have no intention of having a family
with and are just really looking for the
next best thing
another story August 2022 at 34 years
old this is from Julian sounds it all
began with the appearance of Andrew
Tate's YouTube reels which started
showing up one after another following
that I encountered Kevin Samuels The
Godfather
um Kevin Samuels astroately pointed out
that I exhibit characteristics commonly
associated with a male lesbian a simp a
beta a man with feminine traits through
the insights of individuals such as
Andrew Tate Kevin Samuels Pearl Rich
Cooper fresh and fit and Sarah Don Moore
among others I've gained a better
understanding of myself than what it
means to be a man I've also become more
aware of certain aspects to watch out
for in a woman that has previously
escaped by notice and that's why guys
the red pill is is so important
it is so important for men to share
their insights about women with other
men because
this time in history is so unprecedented
there I I don't there have been very few
times in history I if ever where women
have had this many sexual partners
and the idea that women cannot be
predatory with a system that backs them
up is is really silly we really need to
stop you know criticizing the red pill
because it does save lives and you know
there are men that have this idealistic
view of women and when it goes south you
know they they end up killing themselves
and a lot you see this a lot with like
younger guys and that's why this
information is so is so important of
older guys passing down wisdom to
younger guys and this used to happen
before women policed every space that
men were in you know men would go to the
bar or they would go to the gym or they
would go they would have these all male
spaces where they could bring in their
insights about women but the problem is
women have invaded every single male
space and men can no longer share their
insights so what do they do they go
online and then what happens online you
know
women come in and tell men how to talk
women come in and say and shame them for
having these conversations and these
generalities about women there's a
reason there's a reason fathers used to
keep their daughters away from the bad
boys because they love them even the
nice innocent daughter there's a reason
we have a million stories
um in the media of a nice girl you know
just trying to tame the bad guy
um I think Romeo and Juliet this guy got
her to kill herself in a day
you know Romeo and Juliet took took
place over the course of a day
I mean there's a reason that the dad was
like we got to stay away from this
um you know and you see that in in the
movies too it's like the the sweet nice
it's on Bonnie and Clyde Bonnie was like
this nice girl and then she met Clyde
um and there's a reason that I see this
trend of women on the show they'll date
entertainers and rappers and these quote
unquote you know more notoriously Bad
Boys in their 20s and I'm not saying
women don't learn and then choose
accordingly
but do we ever really know I want to say
we do and you know maybe some do but
guys we have to be able to give
generalities and talk about the rule
before we talk about the exception we
know there's exceptions but
you know I I really think as women we
should really promote honesty let's be
honest
um the reason I ask that they bring
these stories up is because I really do
think we need to start as women
understanding where the men are coming
from I think we cannot improve you know
a lot of times the Trad cons will come
in and say pearl what is your solution
um which is a bit disingenuous because
who am I to solve all the world's
problems but I gave them a couple one
men only marry virgins everyone else
doesn't deserve marriage they don't
deserve your commitment sorry not sorry
number two women shouldn't vote merch in
the bio go get it guys
um but number three is actually covering
these stories the stories that make
women look bad the stories that don't
get mainstream media attention and
letting men talk about their
observations about women so they can
adapt and act accordingly because
honestly men are very benevolent in
general man are very nice to women men
have always been meaner to other men
than to women and I think that's why the
red pill is such a hard time because so
many men have this gut reaction to just
like protect women
um at all costs and
you know when you give men power and
information they usually act in a
logical way and if they start abusing
that power other men will come in and
police them and so as women I really
think we gotta we gotta just let the men
talk let them do their crude jokes and
stop whining stop cabutting in and
saying that's not funny stop butting in
and telling men how to be men
and whining thank you
there is always a risk of investment and
there's no guarantee of any kind protect
your retirement with gold Ira or go to
www.justburlythingsgold.com or call
877-646-5347 Noble gold is who I trust
the US has lost 85 percent of its value
since the 70s when the dollar decoupled
from gold and the government seems bent
on continuing the tradition from now
until after the next elections the
government can print as much money as
they want and the last time they did
that inflation went up nine percent gold
is the one asset that has proven to
withstand inflation invest in gold with
a noble asset Investments you will also
get a 24 carat quarter ounce gold
standard coin for free go to
noblegoldinvestments.com now that is
noblegoldinvestments.com or simply dial
1-877-646-5
five three four seven noble gold
Investments the only gold company that I
trust
all right so Reddit has come again for
Pearl you know I you know I used to say
on the show Pearl doesn't give
relationship advice because and the
reason I used to say that was because
um I just felt like
men really should ask other men you know
I just think in general men give the
best advice however I do think you're at
a low point if you're on Reddit asking
for advice
so today I'm going to respond to a
Reddit store out of the kindness of my
heart you know I'll give you my opinion
take it or leave it so
yesterday I told my husband I wanted
divorce his birthday is next week what
do I do
I have a separate post on the reasoning
why I want a divorce I desperately need
insight there as well anyways my
husband's birthday is next Saturday we
had plans to go away next Saturday to
Tuesday with his family I'm not going
with them anymore but I'm not sure how
to proceed with his actual birthday on
Saturday I told him I still want to
celebrate with him and he said no
because he wants to celebrate with his
wife and that's not me anymore he's
heartbroken I wanted to buy him gifts
and a card and cake like I normally do
but I don't know what to do I feel like
I'm in a nightmare I can't wake up from
so okay you see this
she wanted to do an action with no
consequence and guys this is why you got
to stop giving your Ex-Wives your
ex-girlfriend's attention if a woman and
even your women in the friend zone
because it honestly allows us to be bad
people yeah you shouldn't put up with
this and a lot of reason the women are
the way they are is because you guys put
up with this [__] so
and this is good okay this is what he
should have done she said I don't want
to be your wife anymore
and she's trying to still get the
attention from him and spend time with
him and attention is to women as the
Sexes to men okay and when you get this
through your head you realize you're
basically fueling her to have bad
behaviors the more you give her
attention for you know putting a guy in
the friend zone now she gets attention
out of you but you get no sex it's not
an equal relationship this guy realized
that now there's a consequence and she's
devastated okay
at it I'm not spending his birthday with
him I understand and respect his
feelings he's part of a softball team
with his sister so I'm coordinating with
his sister to do a celebration for him
but him not knowing that I have anything
to do with it
wow my husband and I spoke with our
marriage counselor today and we have
developed a tentative plan we're going
to do a separation for the rest of the
year I'm going to move into another
apartment we aren't sure if we're doing
the contact versus non-contact during
this time we'll be doing individual
counseling he admitted to not putting
enough effortlessness but despite
wanting to he doesn't know how he told
me that I am the only thing that makes
him happy no and is aware that this
isn't healthy and wants to change I will
do counseling for my own standing mental
illness to end to live with the guilt I
feel horribly I broke his heart in his
kit and it kills me okay
so now
do you see what he's doing he's putting
her on a pedestal he's saying you're the
only thing that makes us me happy and
guys women we hate this we it's like
okay you know the gut feeling that guys
get when a woman just sleeps with them
on a first date where they're like oh
[__] this is a [__] women feel that way
when you put us on a pedestal and just
give us commitment off the bat women
always we want to feel like we worked
for the commitment I don't know why
we're wired this way it's not a logical
thing but we're just led by our emotions
so now he's starting to put her on a
pedestal and I'm gonna guess okay and I
haven't heard the story yet so what
we're gonna see but I'm gonna guess now
that he's putting her on a pedestal and
basically saying she can do whatever and
still have a chance to be with him and
not have to do anything to make up for
the bad behavior she's going to act
worse
and the other thing is you see a sneaky
women are it's like you said I don't
want you to do anything with my birthday
and she still finds a way to do it
it's a non-submissive wife it's a wife
that doesn't listen
um
and then another thing I want I want to
point out is he said
he admitted that he has not put in
enough effort despite wanting to but
doesn't know how so this equate this
means
um she said he needs to spend more time
at home maybe he works too much or
whatever and
she won't she'll never be happy that's
what this equates to that's that's the
equivalent because you know and I want
you to like think of this if you said to
a woman okay step by step what would
make you happy right now what would make
you happy most women don't even know
we don't even know
we're just silly all right during this
time we will both be free to explore
other relationships he is hesitant to
explore but he said he may at the end of
the year we will decide if we're going
to stay together or divorce okay here
you go she's trying to see if she can do
better she doesn't think she's going to
lose him I bet you if he found someone
else that she deemed is better than her
younger and hotter I don't know what
women think is on the other side of this
do you think being a single mother is
going to be better
really like do you think this is good
all right good luck all right we are we
are aware of the risks of this there's a
ton of unknowns I genuinely hope that at
the end of this we end up together and
come out on top I want it to be him in
the end okay so you want so instead of I
don't know working through your marriage
how okay like like make this make sense
you're now gonna live in separate houses
and you think that's gonna make your
marriage better
you want him to put in more effort and
your solution is to see him
less
um but the regrets I have are too
overwhelming to ignore we own a house
right now and we were not ready for it
we agreed that if we make it out
together we will sell the house in the
suburbs and rent an apartment in the
city
that's a bad idea that's okay so you
know this is the did she really give a
real reason for the divorce I I not
really a good one so my my opinion on
this is is work it out uh you know I
Pearl's gonna give her advice there's my
advice okay
um Step One to to the woman asking for
advice apologize yep
go between your legs tail between your
legs and say look
I don't know why I did this I was being
emotional
um and I wanted to control the marriage
and it turns out
that and now insert thing he does while
you're really hard working man you're
this you're that
what your great father great husband and
I didn't appreciate that
okay that's step one apologize
and I was wrong for trying to control
you
and nothing you did would ever make me
happy
I was wrong for relying on another
person to make me happy
step one apologize admit where you're
wrong this is really hard for us chicks
to do I know
it's like accountability is Kryptonite
then say I don't want a divorce I want
to work it out
right right
and then step three
um
don't see other people
and get off of I don't know what there's
got to be some media here influencing
her because women we our ideas all come
from somewhere typically
um I'm not saying like some women are
just like that but if she was a good
wife and mother before there's probably
something influencing her so figure it
out so figure out what's influencing you
maybe it's your friends maybe it's the
media you're consuming there's something
that's influencing you to make this
decision whatever that is you got to cut
it out you got to just get rid of it
whatever thing is making you feel like a
victim and that's influencing you to be
this selfish maybe it's just who you are
then it's time for character development
then it's time to improve as a person
and maybe get some older wives right
that have been married and believe in
true submission to Mentor you
and that's the thing it's really tough
for us younger women I women under 40
I'll say to find good mentors because a
lot of women just were not taught
um submission we were really just taught
this egalitarian model and you know that
you could see the trends of this because
you know you'll see people let's well we
have to have balance well what is
balance typically
listening to the woman
that's that's Pearl that's advice from
Pearl I'm the advice giver now ask Pearl
that could be a whole segment ask Pearl
what does Pearl think
um
so
next
Logan Paul Logan Logan Logan and you
know it's unfortunate all this is going
down because I really I do think he's a
hard worker and I think it's unfortunate
to watch a guy build an entire career
just to be embarrassed by a chick I
think I I feel really bad for the guys
like this so you know Logan Paul again
he's fighting Dylan danis and Dylan
danis all week has been tweeting picture
after picture after picture of of
Logan's fiance with other chicks now I'm
gonna I'm gonna be fair some of it is
just taking pictures with guys but but I
think we're at over 75 pictures she was
a model so there's a lot of nude shoots
there's a lot of risque photos so let's
let's
um and Logan has finally responded to
Dylan Dennis so let's let's pull the
clip I know who Nina is she knows who I
am we've been so transparent about each
other's past she's a [__] angel she's
had long-term boyfriends her whole life
uh every guy in the world wants to date
her only a few could and say they got to
I'm the one that was lucky enough to
lock her down uh and it's so stupid that
I have to come on here and like clarify
the fact that my supermodel girlfriend
who's had an amazing career and has
built an amazing life for herself got
Paparazzi with her exes like yeah she
took pictures with her exes yes guys
came up to her I wanted to take photos
including LeBron who [__] came up to
her and wanted a photo yes she's done
professional modeling shoots and said
provocative [__] because it gets clicks
like she's in the industry she's in
Hollywood and again it's so stupid I
have to clarify this but like me and
Nina are good we [__] love the [__]
out of each other she's my fiance I
cannot wait to marry her and Dylan just
takes it below the belt and bro at one
point I was the most hated person on the
planet right I don't give a [__] what
anyone says you know you're not me you
don't know my life you don't know Nina
you don't know me so shut the [__] up
live your life you can comment on mine
but at the end of the day I don't give a
[__]
thank you for saying I can comment on
yours because that's what I'm gonna do
I'm here I'm ready okay
um all right so I actually didn't think
this was the worst response in the world
I actually thought it was decent right
um I I a couple things you can kind of
tell when a guy has a more like blue
pilled mentality a bit more naive and
that's why a lot of times guys will say
in the manosphere that you can have
money but it doesn't mean you understand
women and you can get women but it
doesn't mean that you under understand
them because really
um in my opinion she's just running like
game a bit on him
um do you really think LeBron James
wanted a picture
with this model that nobody heard of
until she started dating you
that does that doesn't really make sense
to me that you know
um
and this idea like he he's almost
um judging her on masculine standards so
she's saying she built this amazing life
for herself she had this amazing career
and this is what guys have been told to
judge women on and to act like
brainwashing doesn't work on that is
definitely false like you see men
emoting like women speaking like women
because you know they go into they're
raised by a lot of times either single
mothers or really domineering mothers I
don't know much about their home life
but if I had to guess it's probably a
more domineering mother that doesn't let
the the husband lead right
um
uh he doesn't give me the single mother
home like I think it was probably a
domineering mom but yeah and you see him
judging his fiance on masculine
standards a career
um long-term ex-boyfriends but I was the
lucky enough one to lock her down well
maybe there's a reason they didn't lock
her down you know typically I mean
typically Superstars you know when a
woman's a unicorn
men will lock her lock them down you
know what I mean or it also shows a lack
of ability to commit now she actually
seems very nice so I I'm not even trying
to go too in on her but my point is this
there's a lot of red flags coming in and
I do think this is gonna red pill a lot
of guys that you know just because she
waits to sleep with you it doesn't mean
she's innocent she could just be
sleeping with Iraq's boyfriend or
someone else and you know that's why you
have the fresh and fit guys that say
sleep with 50 women before you commit
because otherwise you kind of get
bamboozled like this that's why the
Freshman got fit guys would say well
most women are [__] so treat them like
such so you know if she doesn't sleep
with you on the first date She's Not
That Into You because there's probably
someone else that's it and you know I
don't
I don't say that to be all women but you
know on a balance of probabilities is
probably in present day it's probably
more that do that than don't
Logan Paul I I really wish them the best
but it'll be I think he's gonna marry
her I totally thought he was gonna drop
her after all this stuff came out but
yeah looks like he's gonna marry her
all right we're gonna dip into the trans
the trans people again
so
recently there was a governing board
that had to hear the testimony of a
trans person just fighting for their
rights so why don't we pull the clip so
I'm the scary [__] they all warned you
about
me I'm the one that you think is
grooming your children
aside from the people who want us dead
so allow me to introduce myself my name
is Love Bailey yes love is my first name
I'm the child of a military family my
grandfather fought many wars as a
colonel in the Air Force so that you all
could be free if he were alive today he
would be disgusted by what's happening
right now this is supposed to be a
country that celebrates diversity a
country founded on the principle that
all men are created equal nowhere in the
constitution does it say that you were
only free if you're bleach white
straight the gender assigned at Birth
and racist
my grandfather would be proud of the
human I have become today no one groomed
me to transition and because of freedom
I chose to be who I wanted to be and I
turned out damn [__] amazing
when you force someone to be outed for
something so personal they're going
through you make it very dangerous for
them putting a Target on their back for
bullies to make fun of or he's a problem
thank you
[Music]
and I have to say I'm a little afraid of
this person
I think if we were alone and I said some
of my opinions that
he might beat me up you know what I mean
like I'm not I'm not trying to so
they're like I'm the afraid the trans
person I'm like ah
keep me away
and they're like you don't know any yeah
cause I don't
mentally ill people I don't typically
try to hang around I don't want to be
around mentally ill women either I think
it's a headache I think it's tough
um and the other thing you notice who
was clapping
women because women are the ones that
buy into this stuff funny thing is 80 of
the trans movement is women it's mostly
women that fall into these ideologies
and the men that fall into are usually
women-led
usually they're led by some woman's
emotions yeah I I think the point of the
matter is
um what what a lot of these left-wing
people will do is they resort to calling
you a racist shaming you for being white
like what does being white have to do
with being trans
that's what I was thinking I'm like what
does being white have to do with this
what
what and when did that when did that
become a bad thing like when did that be
an insult
you know I like sorry I
whatever whatever but
and the fact that they were all
applauding
really how do I go to one of these
meetings can someone let me know in the
com in the comments because I really I
want to attend one I think I would do
really well and I really want to give my
opinion
yes Pearl gives her opinion I know
women's opinions shouldn't matter
but for whatever reason I grew up in a
time period where mine does so I'm I'm
here and I'm ready to give my oh so
important opinion so yeah guys we really
gotta just
start calling out this nonsense
especially men I really want to
encourage men to when else women are
acting insane or just doing some crazy
[__] please help us out we don't
know any better we're like kids like if
your kids walking around
um acting and saying throwing a temper
tantrum in the grocery store you you
scold the kid right but women we have
these childlike brains and
we're in a society where the men can't
tell us anything even though we act like
children you know the US dollar has lost
85 percent of its value since the 70s
when the dollar decoupled from gold and
the government seems bent on continuing
this tradition from now until after the
next elections the government can print
as much money as they want and the last
time they did that inflation went up
nine percent that means one thing the
security of your future and your
family's future is all in your hands
make sure you freeze the value of the
wealth you are holding invest in gold
with Noble gold Investments gold is the
one asset that has proven to withstand
recession inflation and just above all
economic threats Noble gold Investments
is here to help you if you want to
invest in gold you will also get a 24
Karat quarter ounce gold standard coin
for free go to
noblegoldinvestments.com now that is
noblegoldinvestments.com or simply call
one eight
877-646-5347 Noble gold Investments the
only gold company that I trust
okay so I was scrolling through Tick
Tock and guys I found this
um account that I think is so funny I'm
gonna react to some of his videos this
week
um and he had a video talking about why
women are dating down nowadays and
really I'm talking about women's
reasonable standards so pull the clip
seeing a trend of women dating down
which means you know a man who
so it looks like women are getting
victimized again uh women are having to
date down because there are no good men
left let's talk about why
so usually men make more than women
which is not fair let's not talk about
why we'll just assume it's oppression so
to combat the suppression we need the
government to make laws so that women
can make an equal amount of money which
is fair and once women are making an
equal amount of money now uh men who
make less than them are [__] losers
women are getting educated and they have
standards so they're not going to date
down she needs a man who makes more
money than her which is not fair
government help
so basically women need to be making the
same amount of money as men or even more
because it's 2023 that's the year that
it is that's this is the year and so the
government has to make this happen
because it's it's August 23rd the logic
is flawless
so all women should be equal to or
better than men and all women should be
able to find a man who makes more money
than she does where have all the good
men gone I just don't get it
I just don't understand it I got
educated and that's something that men
care about a whole lot
so now me and all the other educated
women are looking for men and they're
all busy what's going on here
I want a man who makes six figures
because that's more than me and that's
not fair so I should be making six
figures and when I get my six figures I
I want a man who's making seven figures
why can't I find any and when I do find
a man who makes seven figures that's
oppressive government help I'm so sick
of all this dating down why don't you
just do better hey you can't do better
government
why can't I raise my standards and make
a lot of money and then find a guy who
makes more money who doesn't have a lot
of women I just don't get it it's the
mystery of our time
guys it's really simple you gotta get
out there and and climb that ladder and
when you do climb that ladder then
you're an evil bastard and you need to
be forced to share and when you do share
then you're a [__] loser better climb
that ladder buddy
why can't all men be better than all
women while we also have enforced
equality it just does not make sense
I thought this was such a genius way to
put it because this is exactly what
happens the government comes in and adds
these quotas they discriminate against
men for jobs they overpay women for
doing the same work as guys and actually
pay women more per hour and you'll see
this trend of smart educated women dying
alone
and really um the women that I think of
that over like I don't want to say
overcame this but
um like the women that I see that are
smart and educated
have to they have to date quote unquote
down I'll give you an example that chick
from precious the Gabrielle Gabrielle
tick
um she dated down the girl from Bumble
Whitney wolf heard she dated down Oprah
dated down and I'm not saying dated down
in all aspects you know I'm sure they
outdid her in them and some but it's
just if you're gonna make a lot of money
as a chick you have to understand what
comes with it what is supposed to come
with it it's either you date down
you quit your job
then you date up or you die alone and
the problem is we've told women that we
can just have it all yes Queen have it
all you can have the career and still be
treated like a traditional woman
and I think that's where a lot of like
tradcons are are a bit especially the
women are a bit disingenuous because
they pretend they are the Ultimate
Picture Perfect of traditionalism but
really if you didn't get married before
25 you're probably not doesn't mean bad
person
um but now the issue is women want the
best and if we don't get the best then
we somehow find a way to blame the men
and you'll notice in a lot of these
clips they'll they have themes right
it's always the men need to be better
it's never the women need to be better
it's that there aren't enough men to
marry where are the men to marry but
then we don't ask the question well
where are the wives and in all honesty
guys I think there's more husbands than
wives you know the average guy's
stronger than the average woman so the
average woman is going to get a bit of
protection I'm not saying a lot
but better than living alone right
um provisioning the average guy still
makes more than the average woman in his
lifetime
um chicks that monetize Beauty are an
exception but the average guy still does
make more so even though you might have
to work he still offers more
provisioning
um but do women typically offer
femininity do women typically have
Homemaker skills and you know I don't
even completely blame women for this
because we everyone's a victim of the
time and that's when we look at
different time periods we really have to
understand that things were normal at
the time in this time period this is
what's normal and unfortunately
um we live in la la land as chicks and
I'm really thankful for
um shows like Kevin Samuels like Russian
fit that are honest because when you're
honest with women at least women that
want to improve and make adjustments
can't but we live in this Society where
the men lie to us the media lies to us
commentators lie to us the left and the
right lies to us politicians lie to us
and women get to 45 never having
been told the truth about the world
until our Beauty goes and then once our
Beauty goes we start to get a little bit
more humble but a lot of times for a lot
of women it's too late especially with
the development of Botox
um all of these surgeries that we can
get bbls which keeps our Beauty for
longer
um and gets attention from men and
extracting resources from men through
beauty or longer look at Kim Kardashian
like that chick she looks young she's
still beautiful right
um but really it's not like natural and
vanity used to be a sin but now it's
celebrated and I had this thought I was
thinking about how women were not
supposed to look at ourselves that much
you know they didn't have mirrors like
that you know 200 300 years ago like
they weren't everywhere but now women
are
so good at taking selfies we've like
we're like the queen of stuff like we've
looked at ourselves so much that we know
how to angle we knew the best angles we
know the best makeup like think about
how much time you have to spend looking
in the mirror to get good at makeup to
get good at all of this [__] like when
before you were supposed to focus on the
family vanity was second and that's why
I don't really get that I don't really
get up in arms when these women will
attack me for my looks because really
these women have been looking at
themselves for way too long and they
think they're a lot hotter than they are
and a lot of chicks literally think they
look like their Instagram filters they
literally think they look like they do
in good lighting
um when really we don't actually look
like that and if you look at pictures
from like the early 2000s it's a lot
more honest well now now you look at an
Instagram reel
and you know I've had girls come on the
show and I look at their Instagram I
don't even recognize them but women were
literally convinced that we are we like
become our filters
um so you know talking about female
nature right women have a tendency to
over exaggerate and lie much more than
men that's why instead of believe all
women it should be believe no woman and
really we need evidence and you need to
prove it so boxer gerventa Davis we have
the same last name uh was arrested for
domestic violence and spent 44 days in
jail the charges against him were later
dropped but he still will have to live
with the stigma of being accused of
domestic violence the Maryland Police
Department released the video of Davis's
arrest which showed him being
uncooperative with the police he was
initially sentenced to 90 days of house
arrest but he violated the terms of his
sentence and was sent to jail
professional Combat Sports athletes are
held to a higher standard of conduct
than the general public and they can be
prosecuted even if they do not get into
a major altercation with anyone cases
like Davis's should be studied by other
members of the police force so they can
learn to handle these situations in a
safe and effective manner so pull the
footage did anything with him I'm at my
house
what
is your first name yeah okay what you're
listening to Davis on December 27th 2022
the Broward County Sheriff received a
desperate 9-1-1 call from a woman who
expressed fear for her life she reported
being punched in the face by her live-in
boyfriend during an argument the suspect
was identified as the renowned
undefeated professional boxer javonta
Davis
and repeat that Pizza address I need to
send units to you I need the address
what's the address
all right
so there's a couple things I wanted to
point out from this clip one
does it make sense that a boxer was
beating his wife and all she had was a
bruise on her lip
think about it this guy is trained to
punch people
if he wanted to punch the woman
wouldn't she be knocked out and the
other question I have is what brought
this anger out of him if he allegedly
punched her because what women do a lot
of the time is they taunt a guy they hit
him first and a lot of times the the lit
is from them trying to get the woman
away from them
and a lot of times their their abuse is
from the men trying to get the woman off
of them
but
the officers
um I don't think handled the situation
accordingly but I'll tell you why I
think men have an innate instinct to
protect women and I think women know
this and use it against the men
and so you'll see he said why is he
getting arrested and the officer said
he's stronger now the reason that the
officer said that is because under the
Duluth model it's typically and I can't
remember the actual wording but the
Duluth model switched the way that
police do policing in around the 80s and
what this did was basically assuming
women the stronger person has power and
is trying to use that against the weaker
person the person that is stronger which
is typically men is the person that is
seen to be the abuser that's why you see
these men that call the police and then
the women
um end up the men will call the police
on the women and then the men get
arrested like we've seen case after case
after case of this
um and the reason is you know feminists
have infiltrated the legal system the
justice system the police system and
they really switched the way that laws
are written and they have implemented
laws that discriminate against men you
see it in the court system too you know
around the same time period they
switched it to where the caregiver that
spends more time with the kid
automatically gets custody well
um if a guy wasn't protecting and
providing for his family then he would
be the demon but if he does it then he's
punished and you'll see these laws that
might not necessarily you know say a
gender but it's very easy to imply who
it is you know are there occasional
women that are stronger than Venture but
by and large who who's going to be
discriminated against um for switching
to the Duluth model
um
so and the other thing I wanted to point
out was he didn't want his daughter to
be outside because he didn't want to see
what was going on I think personally so
I really I I think the officers really
need to be trained on female nature
I I think that this would help I think
that they need to get rid of the Duluth
model I think it doesn't make sense I
think we've really got to start thinking
through does it make sense that a boxer
and we see all of these women coming out
with abuse allegations against Fighters
uh really
like they
they hit you really
a boxer
um yeah and again when women get angry
we just follow our feelings so if we
feel like we're beat in that moment if
we feel like we're being abused that's
what we say and the issue is we have all
this propaganda and all of this legal
jargon that backs us up in a legal
system that'll back us up and it'll just
allow us to live in this delusion and it
doesn't
and unfortunately now we see men's
careers and lives being ruined based on
a system and in my opinion discriminates
against men so
um let me know what you guys think in
the comments
um how do you think the officer could
have handled this situation better and
tell me more what your thoughts are on
the Duluth model and and how we can
improve the criminal justice system but
let me know what you guys think guys
like the video on your way out also
please please please guys buy my merch I
want to walk around and just see people
with these t-shirts that say women
shouldn't vote I think would be so funny
so like the video on your way out guys
subscribe to the channel and I'll talk
to you next time